[Music]
on this friday night america's landmark
reversal on abortion rights
this is a sad day for the country but it
doesn't mean the fight's over
the u.s supreme court overturns roe
versus wade this decision is a victory
for the pro-life movement the fears of
what's next and the potential effect on
canadian women ukraine retreats and
russia advances
the significant victory for
moscow and
party on
[Music]
canada's biggest pride parade is
returning to the streets of toronto
[Music]
global national with bara nasser
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us
in the declaration of independence the
founding fathers of america wrote all
men are created equal
not today
for 50 years women in the united states
had a choice over their reproductive
rights but their right to illegal safe
abortion has now been taken away
the overturning of roe vs wade didn't
happen overnight it was decades in the
making with the stacking of conservative
justices
today's debate is when does life begin
yesterday the question was what is a
life worth after the same supreme court
made it easier to carry a loaded firearm
in public
now there's a lot to get to tonight
including what this means for us here in
canada but let's go first to jackson
prosko who is in front of the supreme
court on this historic day jackson
pharah the reaction to this ruling was
immediate and the consequences for women
in dozens of states are quickly coming
into focus as they learn that they will
have fewer rights than the generation
that came before them
this is what anti-abortion groups spent
decades preparing for
a moment that lays bare america's tilt
toward the conservative christian right
ultimately we believe that life begins
at conception and that each of those are
worthy to be protected and to be loved
bro
the highest court in the u.s did what
was once unthinkable overturning its own
prior decision protecting abortion
access
for the first time in nearly 50 years
states will decide what rights women
have there are no guarantees of access
to abortion care anywhere in america
it's going to limit it in many other
states and that means babies will be
saved and women too
[Applause]
for pro-choice americans it's a brutal
defeat and a worrying sign of what's to
come i'm worried that they're going to
come after my contraceptive rights my
right to have an iud my right to birth
control i'm worried that they're going
to come after gay marriage next i think
it's a complete setback for women's
rights i am very upset but i know it
will not stand
they may make a law but it's not going
to stop abortions the practical effect
is that half the states will soon ban
abortion entirely including mississippi
home to the women's clinic at the center
of the landmark ruling we have so long
with this privilege of being able to
make this choice
the decision is stunning but not
unexpected after a draft of the ruling
leaked last month the court's
conservative majority put the writing on
the wall long before that this is a very
dangerous decision this is a radical
supreme court that republicans have been
working for a long time to pack this
court with extreme right justices the
president finds himself powerless to act
even though the majority of americans
support some form of access to abortion
it's a realization of an extreme
ideology and a tragic error by the
supreme court in my view
the court has done what is never done
before
expressly take away a constitutional
right
that is so fundamental democrats have
vowed to pass a law restoring the
federal protections of the original roe
versus wade case but it's unlikely
they'll have enough republican support
to do it
the stakes in november's midterm
elections are now that much higher
all the while the fate of other rights
granted by the court are now equally in
doubt
jackson it may not have been a surprise
but it certainly came as a gut punch for
many and many americans are now
wondering if this is going to mean the
end to other rights that they may have
taken for granted what do we know right
now you heard plenty of those concerns
in our report and they're not
far-fetched pharah in fact one of the
justices today in a concurring but
separate opinion actually said that it
is time for the court to revisit all
sorts of precedent-setting cases
including the rulings that legalize
same-sex marriage and decriminalize
contraceptives in this country the
question is how much will americans
stomach and of course that is a question
they will likely bring to the ballot box
with them this november
farah
certainly jackson prosco in washington
thank you jackson as jackson mentioned
with today's ruling in 13 so-called
trigger states abortion is now illegal
or will become so in the coming days
nbc's cal perry is in missouri where the
state's abortion ban has just been made
official cal
there are 13 states with what they call
trigger laws going into immediate effect
after that supreme court ruling and here
in missouri one of those trigger laws
indeed going into effect after the
attorney general signed a proclamation
that makes abortion at least providing
the service of abortion to women a crime
here a felony b crime which can carry up
to 15 years in prison for medical
providers who do carry out that service
you can see behind me there are some
protesters these are pro-choice
protesters behind me um but this was
expected i think by a lot of people but
still a surprise certainly when it comes
to planned parenthood it was expected
but as they say leaving them still
speechless this center here planned
parenthood in st louis was the only
place where women in the state of
missouri could go to receive an abortion
now of course they cannot even come here
i had the chance to speak to
representative corey bush who represents
the saint louis area as well as the
northern st louis county and she wanted
the women of missouri to know that
abortion is still legal just across the
border in illinois the governor there
making it a priority to keep abortion
legal but it gives you an idea of how
complicated and difficult the situation
is now across the country farah
nbc correspondent cal perry in st louis
thank you for that cal as canadians
watch today's news unfold south of the
border many are wondering if we could
follow suit now prime minister justin
trudeau promises that won't happen but
as abigail beeman reports there are
fears abortion access here could become
limited if an influx of americans seek
care at canadian clinics
dr dustin costescu was working at a
prenatal clinic when the news broke and
patient phones lit up just realizing
this overwhelming sense of loss of
control over
their lives everyone talking about the
u.s supreme court's decision the concern
around the rise of transnational
anti-choice movements is a very clear
one so it's a signal that canadians
should not be complacent worried about
what it could mean for american and
canadian women alike
there are already abortion access
challenges for canadians especially
outside of major cities even a small
influx of americans seeking help here
could overwhelm a health care system
already overstretched we are
dealing with constraints that we've
never had before in terms of personnel
funding and access
to services
patients might find that they have an
abnormal pregnancy later than before
because they can't access the diagnostic
tools that they need some worry about
for-profit clinics popping up in border
towns we don't want to be drawing
doctors away from the public healthcare
system to
go into kind of a for-profit model to
help americans you know even though we
do want to help americans you know but
so we're torn and there's a lesser-known
issue late-term abortions after 24 weeks
are rare but very difficult to obtain
here often canadians are sent to the u.s
while the states that offer them don't
have trigger laws they too could face an
influx of patients see that group of
patients that is sort of missing from
this conversation
right which are our patients that do
have you know fetal anomalies or
pregnancy abnormalities you know these
are wanted pregnancies people are making
the difficult decision to say goodbye to
their babies
anti-abortion groups applaud the
decision it opens up a conversation that
is much needed and it also allows us to
see where our leaders stand in canada we
will always
defend women's rights to choose
and continue to work to expand
access to the full range of reproductive
health and services across the country
but we asked the government a number of
specific questions what are they doing
about access to late term abortions and
how to handle a potential influx of
americans who may travel here and didn't
get any concrete answers abigail beeman
global news ottawa
and as the debate rages on over abortion
rights in the united states conservative
lawmakers lamented the passing of the
country's first gun control bill in
nearly 30 years
mr speaker i'll tell you what saves
lives
the decision we got from the supreme
court today saves lives this bill takes
rights away from law abiding citizens
their second amendment liberties
the bipartisan bill passed by the house
includes enhanced background checks
increased penalties for gun traffickers
and more funding for mental health and
school safety the measure now heads to
president biden who's expected to sign
it into law
the public inquiry into the nova scotia
mass shooting says the federal
government left out critical pages of a
senior rcmp officer's notes when it was
given the file the mass casualty
commission says it wasn't until it
received a second package three weeks
ago that the four crucial pages were
included our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson joins us now with the
details mercedes pharah explosive and
politically damaging handwritten police
notes were missing from the documents
the federal government sent to the mass
casualty commission tasked with
investigating the rcmp response to the
devastating shooting in puerto pick that
killed 22 people
the commission says they had no idea
there were documents missing and only
received the disclosure with the
explosive allegations of interference
months after the original file with that
officer's police notes were sent
and they say they've received no
explanation now they want to know why
that happened and what else might be
missing saying the commission sought an
explanation from the department of
justice about why four pages were
missing from the original disclosure of
superintendent campbell's notes the rcmp
and the department of justice are
legally obligated to provide all
documents that are under a subpoena the
commission also revealed a list of
problems in getting documents from the
feds saying massive disorganized rcmp
files have been dumped on them leaving
them to try to sort through a mountain
of paperwork and figure out what's what
the notes in question alleged attempted
interference by rcmp commissioner brenda
lucky promising prime minister trudeau
and then public safety minister bill
blair that the force would release
information sensitive to upcoming gun
control laws now the question is who
made the decision to withhold these
documents and how much more is out there
pharah mercedes-stevenson in ottawa
thank you mercedes
the prime minister on a mission coming
up how he's hoping to help ukraine
during his trip to africa
[Music]
a powerful aftershock in a remote part
of afghanistan has caused more deaths
that is the toll from wednesday's 6.1
magnitude quake has climbed to 1150
people and that number is expected to
rise the quake destroyed or badly
damaged an estimated 10 000 homes the
few international aid agencies still
operating in afghanistan say the scale
of the disaster has overwhelmed their
resources and those of the taliban
government
prime minister justin trudeau continued
his visit to rwanda where the
commonwealth heads of government summit
officially opened today our chief
political correspondent david aiken is
traveling with the pm who's looking to
build relationships with some of the
commonwealth's smaller nations and sway
others to support ukraine in its fight
against russia david farah prime
minister justin trudeau wanted to meet
face to face today with as many
commonwealth leaders as he could and he
literally went from a to z starting with
the prime minister of antigua and
barbuda and finishing with the president
of zambia my dear brother justin
certainly a pleasure the top priority
for the 30 or so island states here
getting big countries like canada to
help with climate change it is the most
significant threat facing the caribbean
region trudeau is sympathetic always a
pleasure to sit down with a friend from
the caribbean but trudeau's bigger
mission here is to convince leaders of
the 10 commonwealth states that
abstained when the u.n voted to condemn
russia's invasion of ukraine to change
their minds canada believes that adding
the censure of the commonwealth
representing 54 countries and more than
2 billion people will help ukraine one
argument canada is making connect the
dots between russia's illegal invasion
and food shortages many african and
caribbean nations are facing as a result
indeed all leaders here spent about half
the day discussing food security and
food price inflation but it will be
difficult for trudeau to find a
commonwealth consensus on russia and
ukraine because so many key leaders
skipped this summit india and south
africa for example abstained at the u.n
on the russia vote and neither country's
leader is at this summit but officials
tell us they're worried that the word
ukraine may not even be in the final
statement or communique that will be
issued tomorrow when the summit wraps up
pharah
david aiken in rwanda thank you david
ukrainian troops withdraw from a key
battleground ahead the impact this could
have on russia's war
you're watching global national
for weeks ukrainian forces have fought
to hold on to a besieged eastern city
but today keeve has ordered its troops
to withdraw from severe doneesk
[Music]
the retreat is a significant victory for
russia as it aims to take over the
entire donbass region ukraine says
moscow's next target is the neighboring
city of lisensk which would give the
kremlin full control over luhansk's one
of two regions that make up donbass
and here in canada students are heading
to summer vacation and they know that
they'll be back in school in the fall
but in ukraine that's not the case the
school year was cut short when russia
invaded in february and as global's sean
o'shea reports the combination of the
war and the pandemic have made for a
terrible school year
outside this downtown kharkiv school
it's unusually quiet but in a more
dangerous part of this ukrainian city
bombarded by russia
you can hear distant artillery outside
another school what's missing in these
pictures the obvious there are no
children
well canadian kids are thinking about
summer because school's coming to an end
the physical school came to an end long
ago here when the war began in ukraine
this is the backyard at one of the
schools we're at people are living in
the basement people can't come to the
school it's not safe to play in the
playground and the question is when will
it ever be safe again
school director alexander grayanik takes
global news on a tour first stop
downstairs where we meet someone who's
made the school her refuge are you
afraid when you hear those sounds
certainly certainly and all of us
i'm afraid
but is it preferable to be here than
back to where you live yes you're right
irina isn't just sheltering at the
school she's a teacher here for the last
40 years i know this school
when the war began schools here made a
switch in a way canadians know very well
what happened to their school year when
all this happened
[Music]
children stayed home he says they
transitioned to remote learning although
with internet speeds that are relatively
slow in many areas that's a big
challenge at another nearby school you
can see why students aren't able to
study together this school was attacked
in april likely hit by russian rockets
in the middle of the night the building
is a wreck this classroom took one of
the worst hits when the explosions
happened and perhaps in a mark of irony
this classroom was used to teach russian
literature
but in another room the complete
opposite result a room designed as a
shrine to ukrainian culture wasn't
damaged at all the dresses dolls and
other pieces all perfectly intact
including this gryanic's prized
contribution to the collection his
grandfather's 100 year old milking stool
as for the kids the world bank estimates
ukrainian children have lost more than a
year of learning between the war and the
pandemic and it'll cost them 10 percent
per year in future earnings but right
now the issue at hand is getting kids to
school somehow peace would make all the
difference what do you hope happens next
year for the next school year we can't
hope we wait
we wait we don't know
i would hope
waiting to see what back to school looks
like this fall
shawn o'shea global news kharkiv
returns next toronto gears up for the
return of one of the largest pride
celebrations in the world
with the sixth pick in the 2022 nba
draft
the indiana pacers select
benedict matherin
from montreal
[Applause]
a big night for canada is montreal's
benedict matherin was the first of two
canucks taken back to back in the first
round of last night's nba draft
nineteen-year-old shayden sharp from
london ontario went to the portland
trailblazers with the seventh overall
pick and it is only the second time in
history two canadians have gone in the
top 10 of the draft
now after two long years toronto's pride
parade is once again taken to the
streets pride toronto estimates that
nearly two million people are going to
be out for this weekend's celebrations
of welcome change of course for both
participants and businesses in the city
mike trolley reports
bathed in a sea of rainbows at toronto's
gay village is basking in pride's happy
raise
that's where we found nick bobbing his
head to bollywood music what are you
expecting this year
lots of dancing hopefully making outfit
strangers
toronto has one of the largest pride
festivals in the world a staggering 1.7
million people are expected to take in
sunday's parade which itself will have
over 35 000 marchers
organizers tried their best to make the
virtual pride parties of the past two
years fun
and we're all gonna dance together hit
it but nothing compares to the real
thing downtown businesses should be
happy as well with every hotel room in
the city booked
these three friends just arrived from
san diego we came last night just to
hang out and check out the places and
it's very very diverse around here it's
really cool for all the glow within the
pride bubble organizers can't ignore the
real world around them and the recent
increase in anti-lgbt crime there have
been no direct threats to pride but
organizers aren't taking any chances so
they've increased security at all events
most of the attacks are nothing the
community hasn't seen before slurs flags
torn down but canada's anti-hate network
warns of an increase in threats to those
doing lgbt advocacy while concerning the
people we spoke with say they don't
expect that to change
honestly and i've told many people i
appreciate that people go online and
defend us and defend our community and
that we do ourselves but at some point
just ignore them because they want you
to to fight back they want you to
argue and complain and after two years
of virtual pride the lgbt community
would rather just have some fun
microlight global news toronto
and trust me it is a coming out party
like no other that's global national for
this friday night i'm farah nasser and i
want to thank you on behalf of our crew
for spending your evening with us
tonight's your canada is green gardens
trail that's near trout river
newfoundland and labrador we love seeing
your canada please email us your photos
at viewers globalnational.com until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
each other good night
[Music]